foreign
[Music]
thank you
the reason why it is a civilian is that
civilian is a scientist an academic and
you need somebody with the skill and the
experience and the knowledge of how to
operate maintain you know delicate
equipment and that can't be done with
people usually from military background
foreign
[Music]
civilians in space yes look this is
completely normal as you get to a more
mature Space Program when you're
operating an International Space Station
the space station is basically a huge
laboratory and it's a laboratory that's
going to be increasingly filled with a
variety of experiments and Technologies
from around the world
thank you
[Music]
part of it is national pride of course
and the fact that you can demonstrate
such incredible capacity as a
nation-state to put a human being on the
moon nobody's done that for for more
than 50 years and so going back to the
Moon is something that the Western
America has been leading with the
Artemis program and now China is is
getting on board with its own
independent missions foreign